that hiker in Hawaii lost for 17 days in
a forest she's calling her rescue a
miracle Amanda eller is her name she
described her fight for survival as a
spiritual boot camp during an emotional
news conference yesterday Jonathan
Vigliotti is at Maui Memorial Medical
Center in Wailuku Hawaii where eller was
treated for her injuries
Jonathan did eller say there was ever a
time when she I mean I got to ask
she lost hope out there yeah Tony to
start with the hope part of that she
said she had hope for a few days hope
that she would run into somebody or find
a trail that will lead her back to her
car but as you can imagine as those days
went on and no one was in sight she did
start to lose hope she recalled how she
saw and heard as many as 20 helicopters
overhead she told us she would stand on
rocks and try to wave for attention but
nobody saw her until her luck changed in
a major way when I looked up and I saw
the helicopter right over me and he's
pointing right at me I just like fell to
the ground and I started bawling with
family by her side Amanda Ella recalled
the moment she was spotted after going
for a hike in a Maui forest and getting
lost for 17 days I tried all these
different paths and then I was like oh
shoot these are not bike paths you're
not walking path sees a boar pass the 35
year old lived off of wild fruits in
plants but the wilderness took its toll
a day after entering her knee in a
20-foot fall
she lost her shoes in a flash flood I
was sitting in a foot of water on hard
rocks that I knew were digging into my
skin I couldn't sleep I was shaking so
hard that the only thing I could do is
meditate and it was the only thing that
brought me peace the physical therapist
desperately tried to signal for help you
know I was like putting SOS on rocks so
that hopefully they would see them from
above I was putting any kind of clothing
that I could take off my body out so
maybe they could see that there was like
a sign of human being there
then just as she questioned whether she
would ever be rescued her prayers were
answered
my heart just felt through my feet I
mean I just collapsed I had a plant in
my mouth that I was planning on eating
for dinner I don't know how they spotted
me I mean that is a miracle eller says
she has no plans to return to the forest
anytime soon
but she does have a new appreciation for
life grateful for every breath grateful
for everything and I hope I never lose
that
Ehlers legs are still pretty banged up
from walking through all of that pretty
thick brush he's gonna be on crutches
we're told for at least two weeks but
she says she's gonna get on our feet as
quickly as she can remember she is a
physical therapist she says she wants to
focus on her patients healing Anthony
will be great for her to get back into
action Jonathan what if anything did
Amanda allure say she learned from all
this yeah hindsight is always 20/20 she
definitely expressed some regret
specifically with her phone she
purposely left it in the car she wanted
to unplug she says she is never going to
unplug again though keep in mind this
was supposed to be a three-mile jog she
never expected to be the 7-day fight for
her life it is interesting that
meditation was the thing that comforted
her through all this thank you so much
so cold I have to say I think it's
another great endorsement for meditation
because you always hear about these
stories of people getting through very
difficult times I think good time
download your headspace meditation app
and really does work and I can't get in
I'm so fascinated by this woman that she
kept her cool that she was able to get
through know somebody were saying okay
how much longer I can't get enough of
the story I have to say well it may be
as you pointed the meditation thing is
ranging because while she left her phone
behind yeah though it's caused her
trouble that it's the it's the ability
to unplug there we all have that ability
that ability